ben shapiro your your cousin ben shapiro
yes ben shapiro from daily wire
announced that they are leaving
california
he blames terrible governance and
they're moving
to nashville tennessee out of all the
places by the way
if you know nashville tennessee is the
best place to live in taxes yes as far
as taxes goes
it's number one amongst taxes you ever
been to nashville
i you being serious or sarcastic i mean
i just set you up for a good story i
mean yeah i know you've been the next
i've been on nashville god knows how
many times i've
been in nashville tom uh i've been yeah
i haven't stayed there all day long
don't tell me on that tom
you've been or you're not been i've been
there but if i'm there it's not like i'm
like running around you know the country
music cards you're not hitting the scene
yeah
we've been over and over again we've
been asked over and over again when we
would leave california the answer is now
see you nashville gang boom yes 75
employees
good for him good for him to move to
nashville so is anybody surprised by
this move
uh i'm not surprised at all are you so
so it's not about being surprised or not
the two big mounts if you think
mouthpieces in california
one of them who has the most views on
facebook is ben shapiro ben shapiro is
everywhere by the way on facebook
and the other one is on youtube they
both left california yeah i'm not
surprised he left at all yeah
i'm surprised he went to nashville i
guess i wasn't thinking that i would
automatically think texas
i would think other places i wouldn't i
wouldn't think nashville
for good for him though yeah and he said
most of his employees are a hundred
percent with him
excited about it yeah and boy did he
trash california
in his in his little speech that he he
gave for why he was leaving man i think
he's selling stock on california
if you were to ask him the question we
had the other that's right you're buying
though
so one little opinion obviously he's
moving for taxes but there's other
reasons
obviously he's an orthodox jew yeah he
is but so there's a big jewish community
in tennessee i found that well i mean he
says his kids aren't even safe to go
outside he says if they walk around the
block
they will walk into a needle it will
happen don't you think how often your
kids are stepping on needles
well you live in california yeah where
maybe we're lucky that there's not that
many you don't think he lives in a nice
area yeah he does but but
there's still a possibility i mean
brentwood is nice there's homeless all
over brentwood you could step on a
needle there very very easily
very easily so you ever stepped on a
needle i've seen them haven't stepped on
them luckily
i've never stepped on a needle i've
lived you know